santa clarita diet hmm the same old
stories why I'm here
undead woman cannibal part of a family
I mean Hollywood's told it a million
times think about it
when are we gonna come up with the
original idea oh this is my great yeah
no all is my way of saying it's such a
funny idea it's such a great idea
because it's all about a family and then
of course drew Barrymore undead cannibal
but you all love each other and you're
trying to help her with it and so in a
way it follows a lot of the I don't know
principles of a family comedy yeah it's
just got this bizarre core central idea
that really works it's very funny can I
can I be honest with you for a second
yeah I forget what I'm supposed to talk
about it was just about the santa
clarita diet the show you're on there's
nothing I'm not launching into like
something witty here it really is just
that's what it is this shows this shows
great now this
there's nothing witty on this whole card
it's just you know it's just says Santa
Korea diet and yeah you know it's a it's
a show about marriage and that's all it
says but it did we make it did he make
it
it made it sound good right cuz it's
really good yeah it's really good it's a
really good show good show we're very
proud of it this is the real easy part
where you're in a really good show and
then we have a clip of it this is the
part you're in character again it's a
guy who doesn't as a guy who doesn't
know what though he's doing out here
but let me tell you something well you
got to get out of his character and back
to the guy who knows this thing cold
where he's like yeah it's a great show I
love working with Drew and then we got
this clip ah I wish I knew it was that
easy I was doing so well right up to the
end and then I forgot the whole know
your nose it's a great there's nothing
over here
there's nothing forget this there's
nothing here I tell you something next
time I come I'm bringing my own cards
I'm bringing my own because I happened
before really yeah mine time that just
say it's little question it's just a
little question that leads into then a
natural normal conversation which has
not been rehearsed or discussed in any
way look I liked the show don't get me
wrong so I'm really pleased with your
whole thing you didn't even need me for
that I I'm going I'm sorry I ruined it
because you were pitching the show
everything you said was great I wish I
had said that or at least said yeah we
got it you know I don't let me tell you
something I have no idea I got you from
here I got to physically touch me you
come on physically touch me this is a
this is a sacred barrier between a host
and guests it's only to be crossed by
conan track Oh
[Applause]
let's just
we're darn good can you do me a favor I
want to show the clip yeah I just wanted
that's all I want to do I want you to
show the clip if they're looking at the
clip we can be up to other matters if
you know what I'm saying take over this
clip from Santa Clarita diet so we have
a few thoughts on your departure
there's a beautiful overlook at the top
of Pikes Ridge that we sometimes height
to yeah we could lay you down in a
meadow of wildflowers and as the
butterflies a goodbye to the morning -
so - well we say farewell to Gary west
yeah I don't want to do that well we
know you also like porn you could watch
a few girls go at it for a while and
then we could shoot you in the back of
the head there are no wrong choices now
I don't want to die at all all right but
but hey hang on hey what I think Joel is
saying is but but hey hang on hey you
said if we gave the deed to Kayla you'd
be ready to go I have been thinking
about it and I want to live to see Kayla
turn her life around I want to see Haley
grow up you're talking heading off her
face still better look at a new buddy
not my swimsuit guys how do you have
someone to testosterone without balls
[ __ ] you a question Joel season one -
Sam free diet very funny show streaming
now on netflix mr. Timothy Olyphant we
bow to you
you